venom 2 is gonna be a scream well almost
according to a new report by deadline
Sony Pictures are selected a second
villain to feature in the forthcoming
venom sequel which will be directed by
Andy Serkis and star returning actor Tom
Hardy as a man possessed by the titular
symbiotes deadline cites two sources
with knowledge of venom two who have
indicated that the Marvel Comics villain
shriek will be a part of the film's plot
with shriek incorporated into the script
the forthcoming venom sequel slated to
launch in theaters on October 2nd 2020
will feature at least two infamous comic
book villains the first is Cletus Kasady
a serial killer who serves as a host for
the extra-terrestrial symbiote called
carnage in the comics Cassidy is shipped
off to Rikers Island maximum-security
penitentiary after murdering eleven
people there he actually shares a cell
with Eddie Brock who was incarcerated
after wreaking havoc across New York
City as venom Cassidy and Brock quickly
form a deep hatred for one another with
Brock despising custody for killing
people he knew were innocent and
helpless things take a horrifying turn
when it's revealed that Brock's symbiote
venom isn't dead but merely dormant when
it reforms with Brock it leaves a sort
of offspring stuck on Cassidy that
entity turns into a full-fledged
symbiote of its own bonds to Cassidy and
becomes carnage in the first venom film
these events play out a little
differently
Woody Harrelson is seen as Cletus Kasady
in a mid-credits scene in which Eddie
Brock visits him in prison on an
interview assignment Cassidy saves the
line that makes everyone say oh that's
who the guy with the terrible wig is now
get out of here and I will
there's gonna be carnage since it was
basically a no-brainer that carnage
would be in venom too many fans
speculated that shriek Carnage's love
interest might appear in the flick as
well
shrieks real name is Frances Louise
Barisan and she made her print debut in
May 1993 spider-man and limited issue
one drawing the maximum carnage comic
storyline she's introduced as a drug
dealer with a troubled past who gets
busted by the vigilante duo cloak and
dagger in the middle of one of her drug
runs after being imprisoned than the
Ravencroft Institute for the criminally
insane getting shot in the head by a
police officer and spending time in
cloaks dark force dimension Francis has
a few screws loose her descent into
insanity brings her later mutant
abilities to the surface allowing her to
fly manipulate sound shoots sonic energy
blasts from her hands and access other's
minds to manipulate their emotions and
force them to act violently in the
comics carnage meet shriek as he's
breaking free from Ravencroft where
shriek is also being held the to make
their violent escape team up embark on a
cruise from killing spree and create a
makeshift family with the villainous
carrion demo Goblin and doppelganger
it's possible that venom two may plate
shriek inside San Quentin penitentiary
but still see her meat carnage when he's
escaping this would set up a
fantastically fight phul storyline for
the two villains who may or may not
assemble a group of antagonists Powell's
in the new movie
perhaps a bigger question and how shriek
will fit into the venom 2 narrative it's
which actress will fit into the role
itself there's no news yet but deadline
sources say that Sony is primarily
looking at unknown actresses for the
time being whoever ends up playing
streak in venom 2 will definitely share
the screen with top talent in addition
to starring opposite Woody Harrelson as
carnage and Sam Hardy as venom the
shriek actress will appear alongside
Michelle Williams as an weighing Brock's
ex-fiance let's just hope that a lucky
lady who lands her role for venom 2 will
get to wear a better wig than the wild
one Harrelson sported and the first
venom flick check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel
and to the bail so you don't miss a
single one
you
[Music]